uh this morning we're continuing our
special series kindness 101 with steve
hartman who is sharing stories that are
built around themes of kindness and
character and focusing on the people who
have mastered those qualities today's
lesson
fortitude steve and his kids show us
what one woman made possible with a
little patience and a whole lot of grit
good morning everyone this is my
daughter merrell hi and as you can see
we have two forts on our desk this one
meryl made out of stone and this one i
made out of cards now meryl which fort
would you rather live in
stone one right because this fort has
more fortitude the word fort's right in
there what's that word mean though for
that let's go over to ebbet at the
dictionary desk emmett good morning
fortitude is to have or feel strength
yeah in people it's the emotional
strength you need to get through tough
times so that whenever anything bad
blows your
way fortitude helps you withstand the
adversity and there's no better example
of this than the woman in the story
we're about to show you a story pulled
from our archive of amazing americans
the living embodiment of fortitude
kayla mckeon may be washington's most
unlikely power broker
as a lobbyist
the only registered lobbyist with down
syndrome kayla roams the capital
advocating for the national down
syndrome society i'm good
she's an incredible asset to this
organization
sarah hart weir is her boss she's
extremely articulate and she's quick on
her feet and i'm not going to take no
for an answer they hired you for your
communication skills that too and your
charm
you're good at this
it takes a schmoozer to know a schmoozer
but kayla also has a certain sincerity
that can turn almost any politician into
putty i need your help okay
do you need to sponsor i definitely need
you
am i surprised that she's in washington
dc calling on senators and congressmen
yeah
her parents mark and patty say although
their daughter continues to surprise
kayla never really let down syndrome
slow her down they say even at two kayla
had already decided she would drive a
car someday to pass the permit test we
said you have to be able to read so that
gave her encouragement to knuckle down
and start reading and right now she
still reads a book a week
and she got her driver's license too
that's her celebrating after passing the
road test
she's now one of just a handful of
people with down syndrome to have a
license what about that parallel parking
you know i don't know really that's
challenging fortunately today she does
more flying than driving a couple times
a month she leaves her home in syracuse
for her office in d.c where kayla is
focused on passing a law that would make
it illegal to pay people with
disabilities anything less than minimum
wage i got it she says if it passes it
would be a monumental achievement but a
thrill regardless
just to be part of the process
i just love the feeling of
wow i'm here i'm making history
hard to believe
oh yeah
kayla mckeon
lily in the swamp i'll support the
villain
joining us now my friend and my
inspiration kayla
hello hi
steve hi mayo hi emmett hi kayla is it
true you're getting your college degree
now
actually i'm two classes away from my
associate's degree in dental studies
and i just passed my meteorology class
last time wait you passed your
meteorology class yes i dropped out of
that class
that's hard
yeah it's very hard that's a math
did you pass your driving test the first
time
not my first time but my fifth time
how do you not give up
i am very persistent yes i'm tempted
but no that would never happen
seems like a big part of fortitude is
patience and budging congress on
anything i think would take a lot of
patience right
oh absolutely it does where does that
loss stand now talk about patience
because it has to go through many
channels
and you're not going to give up because
you have bought it you've done it okay
well thank you for joining us
absolutely thank you so much
and good luck to you
powering through whatever obstacles you
face today we'll see you next time until
then stay kind
all right meryl we will do our best to
stay kind that's not hard to do didn't
we love kayla we love kayla i love these
steve hartman stories yeah they're so
good i like what kayla said to steve
you're good at this you go kayla you're
good at this too